[Musique]
et
tous
[Musique]
il tout le monde est du même avis on
veut que vous soyez le commande vous
aller sur la lune
le premier homme sur la lune ça va être
un sacré voyage
tu es sûr c'est une aventure riche et
ton père va aller sur la lune notre
mission est si difficile
elle exige un tel niveau d'avancées
technologiques qui va falloir repartir
de zéro a dit dans cette belle bête ça
va être une vraie bombe atomique si ça
explose
il on a eu un problème le module n'est
pas assez sûr je suis pas sûr de pouvoir
tenir très longtemps
c'est pas facile à lire
ils sont morts neil il faut qu'on échoue
ici si on veut pas échouer là haut
à quel prix c'est un peu tard pour se
poser la question
neil c'est peut-être la dernière fois
que les garçons pauvres
tu crois que tu veux revenir à la maison
on a bien l'intention de revenir de
cette mission il s'est pas sûr
[Musique]
3 2
décollage
[Musique]
on a un gros problème
on contrôle la situation
contre les rien du tout
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Musique]